let's bring in peter king nbcsports.com
columnist and of course the must-read
football morning
in america pete thanks for joining us
um the weirdest thing that happened
on the field over the weekend was what
um i would say that
the philadelphia eagles
um looked like
the mid-season 2017
philadelphia eagles um not necessarily
blowing people out all the time but
competent with a good defense and a
quarterback that makes enough plays to
win
and you know obviously uh as the season
went on in 2017
carson wentz got a lot better than that
um
but i would say the eagles coming back
from
their comatose state was the biggest
surprise
the games coming up tonight i mentioned
that uh
i was told that you know tuesday
wouldn't work because it wouldn't be
fair to the chiefs and i
just ran the stats no team has played
three games over a 10-game span
since 1939. how much thought was given
to moving that game
to a stand-alone on tuesday pete
a lot of thought was given to that dan
um and i think in an ideal world that's
what the nfl would have done
it would have given the nfl another day
of significant prime time space
uh but i but i think that
out of fairness it just really wasn't
fair to the chiefs
um and and i think the one other thing
about
all of this is that people
kind of forget too it wouldn't have been
all that fair to the patriots either
just in terms of you know in terms of
competition because the patriots
would be coming home at 4 00 a.m
wednesday
on a very short week to get ready to
play denver
and denver would have had 10 days of
prep time
you know the patriots even though you
can say well the patriots are better
they'll win the game anyway
that's not how you look at those things
and so i think for all concerned
even though this is going to be a very
long day for the patriots
i think it's the fairest way to go about
it adam schefter reported that
no positive test this morning with the
titans here
uh so i guess we're playing football uh
tonight those two games but then where
do we stand with the titans getting
ready for buffalo next week
well the titans to even consider opening
the facility
on wednesday need to have a second
straight day
of uh good news on their
uh covid tests tomorrow morning
and i think then the nfl
will get together with the nfl pa and
decide
if there are uh if if the facility
should be open
i do think there's one thing to consider
here dan that
you know both the nfl and the nfl pa
went into nashville
last week and spent several days
looking into how in the world did this
thing break out the way it did in
nashville
and nowhere else what exactly happened
so we don't know the answer to that but
as i said in my column today
one very highly placed uh
league source said to me last night it's
the marlins all over again
so the nfl has to make absolutely
sure that all the loopholes
that caused that to happen in the first
place
are closed yeah and and i also people
bring this up
you mentioned in your column where
they're like hey just to
push the super bowl back it's not that
easy to just
push the super bowl back you know just
to make up a couple of games but
it can you see a scenario where you know
the contingency plans are
we are going to push the super bowl back
there there of course is a scenario
where they push the super bowl back
um but i as i wrote today
there's no you can't predict what's
going to happen
here's one scenario that was floated to
me suppose that
there are let's say six games that need
to be played that don't get played this
year
and let's just say that not a single one
of them
is a win in your in playoff scenario
that all it would be was finishing out
the season
and or maybe having
uh instead of being the fifth seed
you're the seventh seed
in the playoffs in that case the nfl
almost certainly would not have a week
18 you know on january 10th
to replay these games because they
really don't
mean
whereas if there are six games
and and this is at stake and a division
is at stake and
and all this is at stake i think they
would then be more inclined
to have a week 18. but dan you can't
answer the question
until you're confronted with whatever
the scenario is
the situation with cam newton uh so he
doesn't travel with the team and then
what will be how do they evaluate his
status then for the denver game
well cam newton is going to have to be
negative on multiple consecutive days
before he's going to be allowed to
rejoin the patriots
um and uh over the weekend i heard that
that newton was uh
you know was you know either
asymptomatic
or not showing a lot of significant
symptoms
if that's the case and if he is
okay let's just say then
uh you know he could still show
that he has uh that he still
has a covet
and so he's got to test negative
multiple days in a row in order to be
let back in the building and so
i i don't know where we are with that
dan and i
and the nfl because it protects the
privacy
of its employees you're probably not
going to hear
anything until you hear hey
and he's back in the building i know you
don't
deal in speculation uh you are fair to
coaches but
from what you hear though about these
coaches when it comes to bill o'brien
in houston or adam gase with the jets
you know we talk about hot seats here uh
how warm are those seats in those places
and maybe any other place around the nfl
i think probably in order right now it
would be
one gace two dan quinn
three uh matt patricia and bill o'brien
probably close to being tied you know
all of those
uh positions are in jeopardy
and you know look on the one hand
you could say that hey bill o'brien
has coached that team for six years and
he's won
four division titles that's as many
division titles as the giants have won
in this century so you say well geez you
know
give him a little bit of rope here you
know let him
coach his way out of this but i think
there's a little bit of a weariness in
some sectors
of that organization uh
and also they haven't gone far in the
playoffs
and he hasn't distinguished himself as a
general manager so
we'll see but but again he's got time to
get out of this
but he's really going to have to work
his way out of this and this team
is going to have to be a lot better than
it has been so far
great stuff is always in the column
peter it's football morning in america
peter king from nbcsports.com thank you
for joining us pete
you're welcome dan have a good day all
right